l'amélioration des temps la volonté de
gagner ou plutôt de ne pas perdre non
seulement dans le cyclisme et dans
presque toutes les disciplines sportives
entraîné une surenchère inadmissible la
preuve la voici le chemin de croix du
malheureux simpson je pense que c'est là
dans ce virage la sortie de ce virage
que le 13 juillet 1967
tom simpson trouvait la mort sur les
pentes du ventoux oui c'est ici même
dans une atmosphère étouffante à deux
kilomètres du sommet un homme izac sur
la route
ce coureur c'est l'anglais tom since les
envoyés spéciaux de panoramas maurice
eveno jean louis normand sont là pour
vous présenter ce document exceptionnel
respiration artificielle masque à
oxygène
les techniques de réanimation sont
impuissants simpson est toujours dans un
état comateux état qui nécessite une
rapide évaluation sur le centre
hospitalier d'avignon à 17h40
les médecins ont constaté le décès de
tom simpson et refusé le permis
d'inhumer